the first minister of scotland nicolas
sturgeon has urged the scottish football
club wraith rovers to think again about
its decision to sign a player who is
civil court ruled to be a rapist
i'm joined now by judy hamilton who's
the chair of the rape rovers community
foundation and the labour councillor for
caldi central judy thank you so much for
talking to us when was the first you
heard that um david had been signed to
the club
yes i first heard the news very late on
monday evening very at the last minute
of the transfer window i read it on
social media and what was your reaction
and indeed the community's reaction
i was very shocked to see it because it
had been flagged um
a few weeks ago it was flagged that raid
rovers might be looking at this
particular player and
there was already a reaction from that
and so i was very shocked to see that
they had gone through
with the signing and the reaction of the
community has come in in the last
day or two
they're absolutely
shocked and stunned
and
believe that it gives a a very very poor
message to all of our women and girls
are absolutely condemn the decision
to
um to sign this particular player at
this particular time
what do you make of the manager john
mcglynn saying that um david goodwill
had a proven track record as a goal
goalscorer and that
with signing him it was crucial to the
club's promotion push in our quest to
reach the sbfl premiership it is a great
signing for wraith rovers as a club as
david is the top goalscorer in scotland
uh i think that's very significant and
god only knows that we do need a striker
um however um this particular striker of
all the strikers in all the world was a
wrong decision and he comes with
quite a lot of baggage and this signing
comes with
a number of other things attached to it
and i don't believe that that had been
risk assessed or um
really that the community feeling had
not been really taken on board
which is disappointing because
raythrovers does
um
perform itself as a family club
and we are very
fond of our families of our women and
girls we're very proud of our women and
girls and we're very proud of all the
work that we've done so far and feel
that it's been undone in the stroke of a
pen
well there are many who would argue it's
not just the message it sends to the
women and girls but to everyone
yes it is a message to everyone and in
the community foundation we work with
families we work with older people
we work with um teenagers and we've
had this throughout our whole community
foundation has been absolutely
devastated by this
do you think it's damaging for the club
in the long run
i think it will be i think that these
24 48 hours have been very very damaging
indeed and will continue to be so
but i think some of the damage that has
been done is possibly going to be very
hard to undo
the club have also said that um it
completely respects differing views
on the subject do you think that's what
this is differing views
i don't think it's differing views i
think we condemn
violence against women and sexual abuse
of all kinds i think that's
across the board everybody would condemn
that i don't think that um differing
views on that subject whether there are
different views on the individual
um
maybe there are um you know um
the football club seem to be looking at
the on the park activity and the fact
that he's a good footballer a good
player and that i have no doubt that he
is um but the
shadow of violence against women that
follows him is something that can't be
tolerated
they've also said that they've been
engaging with this on fans and
stakeholders have they been engaging
with you
no we've had absolutely no consultation
whatsoever we were not invited to any
discussions and we've not had any
consultation whatsoever and really it's
the community foundation that has taken
the brunt of this we are the people who
look after families look after children
women and children and look after the
women and girls team um and the women
and girls program starting from the go
girls which are very very young little
girls and right up until the women and
girls team so um
i
reject the fact that they've had
engagement because that hasn't happened
nicholas sturgeon has urged the club to
think again just very briefly what do
you think should happen now
i
i would echo this those sentiments and
ask the club to really think about what
this has done to our community and on
what it's doing um and what the messages
that they're sending out um so yes
we do need to think again i recognize
that the decision around contracts and
things is a matter for the club um and
it's not for anybody else to decide
because there will be contractual and
legal issues around that um but i would
urge them to think very seriously about
the ramifications of this
okay judy thank you so much for talking
to us
thank you